[Music]
the phrase twinning became big a few
years ago when Charlie Sheen coined the
similar phrase winning when people
accidentally ended up matching it isn't
uncommon for it to be called twinning
but what about when you twin with an
inanimate object you won't believe what
some of these people resemble don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up and click the subscribe button to
stay up on our newest videos here are 10
people who twins with random things
teacher and the marker classrooms are
awkward already especially if you are a
teacher there are dozens of little eyes
staring back at you judging your every
move you want to make sure you are doing
a good job and making an impact on your
students you also want to ensure that
you avoid any awkward or embarrassing
moments while standing up there in front
of the class so you probably make sure
to tuck in your shirt tie your shoes
make sure no hairs are out of place you
do anything you can to keep the focus on
the lesson and off of you well despite
all of this teachers efforts she managed
to distract her students anyway and it
wasn't because her hair was out of place
or even that she had something on her
face nope
she was matching with one of the
children's markers and when we say
matching we mean everything from her
hair to her shirt under shirt and jeans
resembled this marker it's really
remarkable actually
this photo showcases a student raising
the marker as the teacher is writing on
the board the side-by-side comparison is
almost too much we don't know how the
kids were able to hold in their laughter
or even try to concentrate after seeing
this girl and larvae no one wants to
hear that they look like a bug unless
maybe they are being compared to a
beautiful butterfly but other than that
bug comparisons are usually a bad thing
unfortunately for this woman when she
donned a tight yellow tank top the bug
comparisons came flooding in the ribbing
in her back and bright neon color of her
tank top make her look almost identical
to a larvae and not just any larvae the
bermudagrass dim maggot larvae Bermuda's
dim maggots are native to warmer
climates like those of South Asia they
were first discovered in the u.s. in
Georgia in 22
no one really knows how they manage to
make it to the States
the bugs usually caused massive damage
to Bermuda grass when the adults lay
their eggs on the tip of the grass
shoots the Flies eggs then hatch into
larvae which is what the woman had the
misfortune of resembling in the tanktop
the larvae then bore inside the chute
and feed on it after breaking into the
u.s. the Bermuda grass stem maggots made
their way to Mississippi Arkansas Texas
and even Oklahoma this just leaves us to
wonder which of these five states was
this woman in boy and hydrent it can be
cold outside in the winter months
depending on which state you are in you
might need coverage varying from a light
jacket to a snow suit the boy in this
picture looks like he's closer to the
snow suit side of the spectrum anyway
when picking out a winter coat there are
a few things that you consider first is
it thick enough will the coat actually
be able to keep you warm
second does it fit right is it too snug
around your stomach is it too short
around your arms and maybe third you
think about how it looks will it match
the things in your closet do you really
like it
finally you think about if it's worth
the money that you would have to spend
on it the last thing you probably would
ever think about when picking out a coat
for your child is if it will make them
match any nearby fire hydrant hmm why
would you it's an absolutely ridiculous
thing to consider but when this little
boy stood next to a hydrant and raised
his arms you bet his mom was wishing she
had spent a little more time searching
for his jacket woman and the walls have
you ever walked into a place and just
felt like you instantly belong like
something about it just called to you or
you instantly fit in kind of like on
Thanksgiving when you come home to your
family and you look around and realize
that you are just meant to be there well
that must have been how this woman felt
when she realized that she matched
perfectly with the walls in the hall she
was walking through we wonder how long
it took her to look up and make the
connection she matches so perfectly that
it looks like it had to have been
planned but from the expression on her
face she finds her newfound twin just as
strange as we do did the person who
designed the shirt also moonlight as a
painter
the side did she get this shirt from a
nearby store is that color scheme just
the theme of wherever she is what is
going on here there are so many
questions that need to be answered but
as for now we think she should probably
just change her shirt what do you think
what would you do if you were matching
your surroundings
phonecase twins picking out phone cases
is usually a fun expedition and nowadays
there are literally thousands that you
can choose from there are phone cases in
every size shape and color you can even
get them as personalized as you would
like when picking out a phone case you
might think about how it will look on
your phone or with the clothes in your
closet or even your purse or wallet
rarely do you consider that you will buy
a case that matches a stranger's outfit
exactly we've heard of accidentally
showing up to parties in the same dress
but showing up with a matching phone
case and outfit combo with a stranger
that's some weird twinning we have to
admit what is the story behind this
picture is the photographer actually
friends with the woman in the photo if
so did they match the phone case to the
outfit on purpose the matching is
dead-on even the shades of teal match
perfectly the only thing that's a little
off is that the striped pattern is on
the bottom of the phone case and on the
top of the woman's body other than that
they are twinning for sure sweater and
restaurant match up choosing a
restaurant can be tricky especially with
so many options around every corner you
have to pick a place with the right food
you have to pick a place with the right
price point you have to make sure
everyone will enjoy it so when you
finally pick a place and settle in you
are hoping to have a nice stress-free
meal but that's not what happened when
this guy went out to eat no sooner had
he sat in his seat then he realized he
was basically a piece of the furniture
the sweater that he chose perfectly
matched the decor of the booth that he
was sitting in we have to wonder if this
man had been to the restaurant before
because how else would this have
happened there can't be that many
sweaters in the world with that pattern
with its bright gaudy pattern it's also
not a normal choice for a top the whole
thing
seems very 90s Taco Bell asked he
matches so perfectly with the booth that
it makes this picture amazing honestly
it's a meme waiting to happen so someone
should get on that until then we at
least hope the food was good vitamin
water with so many people worried about
their health the appearance of vitamin
supplements has been on the rise people
are taking vitamins wherever they can
get them in pills and supplements and in
vitamin infused water there are several
different types of vitamin water out
there but we are sure when this person
chose their bottle they never imagined
that they would come across a person
that matched the bottle so perfectly to
be fair the color scheme of the shirt is
quite inviting so we can see how someone
could buy an outfit with the same theme
just look at how the blue slowly fades
into the white who wouldn't find that
shirt calming we are just wondering what
you do in this circumstance do you tap
the stranger and bring their attention
to the coincidence or do you just let it
slide and laugh to yourself the
photographer doesn't seem very shy at
all and she is holding the drink so
close to its twin it's surprising that
the woman didn't notice the attention
and turned around maybe if she had we
would have been able to see if the
outfit matches the bottle as much from
the front as it does from behind we
guess we'll never know
identical Oyster card if you've ever
been to London then you don't know how
important Easter cards are much like New
York City's subway system
they are pretty much the keys to the
city boy stur cars allow you to take the
tube almost anywhere in the city
they are pretty necessary for anyone who
wants to get around you can refill them
continually an adventure will never end
Joyce Turk ARDS are a natural part of
life in London but are they so integral
that this woman chose her outfit based
on her oyster card that's what it looks
like to us in this picture you can see
the photographer holding up an oyster
card beside the woman walking in front
of her her shirt matches so well with
the oyster card it's ludicrous
but then again soft blue colors are a
popular choice when it comes to clothing
we wonder if this woman routinely
matches her outfits with whatever public
transportation she's taking that day the
public transportation system in London
should probably give her a few free
rides for her
to the Oyster Card we don't see anyone
dressing up to match New York City
subway cards though that is something
that would make an interesting photo
stretch furniture forever picking out
furniture is a unique adventure everyone
likes something different and what looks
good in one room may look horrible in
another the good thing about decorating
your apartment or home is that you can
make it whatever you want
you can add as much of the personal
Flair as you would like if you love blue
you can make your whole house blue if
you like animals you can line the walls
with pictures of pets you have complete
freedom so what happens when you just
love stripes this picture apparently
this woman loves black and beige stripes
so much that she not only made sure all
of her furniture fits the bill she also
bought a matching shirt I think it's
safe to say this love for beige and
black stripes has gone from like -
obsession though it may seem strange she
does look extremely happy in her beige
and black surroundings even her carpet
dust aesthetic her commitment to this
color scheme is really commendable maybe
she got the shirt as a twofer window
with the furniture that would make a bit
more sense do you know anyone who lifts
their furniture to dictate what they
wear perfect tile match finding the
perfect dress can be difficult every
girl knows that once you find the dress
you have to make sure no one else has
the same one and finding the perfect
flooring can also be quite hard both
have to look good and be able to bring
out the beauty around them so when this
place picked out their carpet we are
sure they took everything into
consideration this is why they paired it
with the tile next to it the busyness of
one match the basic color of the other
but when the woman in the picture picked
out her dress we can bet that she never
thought she would blend in to the floor
Soho perfectly especially with two
separate floor patterns it's crazy the
top and bottom of her outfit blend into
the floors so seamlessly it's almost
like she's a part of it maybe she's the
interior designer who picked out the
carpet and tile that would make the most
sense
we would be able to understand how she
came to twin to this level but the woman
in the photograph looks so amused by her
twinning that we have to think that she
didn't know this was going to happen
regardless we are happy that this photo
exists aren't you so it looks like
matching with inanimate objects isn't as
uncommon as we thought at least not for
these 10 people who twinned with random
things have you ever accidentally
twinned with something let us know in
the comments and don't forget to like
this video thanks for watching
[Music]